tonight during his rally in Nashville
the president spoke about Spygate as
we've been discussing take a look so how
do you like the fact they had people
infiltrating our campaign can you
imagine can you imagine
can you imagine people infiltrating our
campaign is there anybody in this big
beautiful arena right now that's
infiltrating our campaign would you
please raise your hand how would take
courage now look you take a look at
what's going on never in the history of
our country has something taken place
like took place during this election by
joining us now exclusively three people
whose lives have been severely and
harshly impacted by robert muller in his
pit bull andrew Weissman's which on you
know former Trump campaign chairman Sam
Clovis former Trump campaign aide
Michael Caputo former Trump campaign
associate Carter page all right good to
see you all let me ask you all a simple
question and I'll turn to you Carter
first war use war use spied upon what
did a spy approach you I'm not sure
Shawn and you know there are two parts
of the fake DNI report of January 6 2017
first is hacking and we know I've been
hacked eventually and the other way
otherwise I don't know I want to make
sure people know this is the Trump
campaign associate this is the guy that
they used the Clinton bought and paid
for phony Russian dossier with Russian
lies to get FISA warned to spy on an
American you're it they lied to those
courts four times and rod Rosenstein
signed off on one of them the last one
which makes it worse because the by then
they knew it was right they were paid
for Russian lies absolutely but you know
but the other part of the DNI report as
well is the fake news government
propaganda and we know now you know
which led to that FISA warrant there was
broadcasting Board of Governors you know
their affiliate we got on to Russia and
why didn't they just say to the FBI in
the spring of 2016 why don't you go to
the Trump campaign say this guy Carter
Page is a [ __ ]
you never met from bright
never why did this go to Trump and its
campaign saying this guy's going to
Russia he works for your campaign we're
worried about him because there's
absolutely nothing to it and I think
they wanted to why were you in Russia
gave a speech you know you can pay for
it zero no it's been reported you're
former CIA FBI operative intelligence
operative it's funny there's a double
standard there as well I had given
information to the CIA and every
operation with your country absolutely
the betterment of your country
absolutely you made these foreign trips
you would be briefed I gave an elective
questions generally I try to be very
confident you were trying to help their
way you would debris you love America
yes and you were trying to help your
country by meeting with Intel CIA people
they asked for my help and I did not say
no absolutely okay um Sam Clovis let's
let's start with you yes sir you were
approached I won't even many leave the
guy was of two weeks before or a long
time before they mentioned his name
you're approached by this guy what did
he say to you what did he want from you
what he really wanted was they used he
used Carter page as the as a person to
gain access to a meeting with me and we
met on the first of September in 2016 in
Washington DC area and I think he used
me to create an introduction to George
papadopolis and I did not know that this
individual subsequently met with George
I have had no idea about that but our
meeting was was totally innocuous it was
so innocuous that I didn't report it up
the the chain of command at all and I
didn't think anything of it in fact I've
never opened in three campaigns I want
Trump to win he's presenting himself
meanwhile he wants information from you
fair statement well you want to know he
didn't gather and try to get any
information for me I think what this
meeting was about was that they used me
as a way to get an introduction to
George he wanted to go to George
papadopolis and I think and he and he is
Carter page to get to me and then he
used me to get to George
and I really think that was the whole
chain of the whole chain of events there
because I really think what the the goal
was was to create a a linkage between an
affiliate of the Trump campaign back to
those emails in an in order to create
more probable cause to create more
probable cause for FISA warrants and
then also to help create a scandal and I
really do think that was the intent and
the intent and purpose of what this
individual was about Mike tell us your
side your side when you were approached
by the spy and imagine if this was
Hillary's campaign imagine civil
libertarians imagine the left and and
the media in this country how different
this narrative would be well I believe I
got least to and and and perhaps more
approaches by by individuals who were
trying to offer information to the
campaign that would have jammed us up in
some way shape or form I mean it's very
clear that salmon and Carter were both
us but approached by a spy I don't care
what they call this spy I mean human
intelligence or whatever you know back
here in Buffalo you can call it you know
elongated cylindrical semolina but we
still call it spaghetti here as far as a
spy as a spy and that's what it is it
I'll tell you they've done more than
this they had to have done more than
what they did with Sam and close at the
same one and Carter they had to a lot
more I mean in reality of known fully
gentlemen we'd all been like that that
guy in Goodfellas you know watching out
for helicopters and tomato sauce all day
long and these guys were going at us
from all different angles I'm convinced
by the way women do in the senator
somebody call a government contractor
what scar was been a senator I don't
think there's one that if they got a
phone call I've got op research on your
opponent you're gonna want to hear this
wouldn't take the meeting
name one and anyone that says otherwise
is a liar
I don't believe them for a second all
right here's the bigger picture that I
want our audience to fully understand
and we know you nearly lost your house
Michael column about you Carter that
says how robert muller ruined my life
nearly ruined my life
listen Shawn it's like what President
Trump always said on the campaign trail
it's not about me it's about us I think
about all of the damage this did to our
entire all of our volunteers on our
committee look at what it did to Sam you
know it's the first time I've had a
chance to be you know talking with him
in over a year and a half and you know
all the support he gave in terms of
talking through a lot of these lies that
were being put out by the US government
and fake media outlets and leaking it's
like a sieve from that special councils
office absolutely yeah Sam I don't know
I've read a lot about you
how was your life impacted by all of
this and you're laughing but I don't
think it's funny well well I'm pretty
calm I have a great faith and and and
again it's great to finally have a
chance to communicate with Carter again
and I will say this one of the reasons I
left government here about three weeks
ago I was in the administration and I
left the administration and one of the
reasons there were many but one of the
reasons I left is because I was tired of
not being able to defend myself yep and
I said that's enough I'm going to come
out I'm gonna take the muzzle off and
I'm gonna talk to everyone I'm gonna
tell everyone what this has been about
and I can tell you what Michael and
Carter have talked about this has been
and I agree with Michael this has been
at they've come at us in multiple
directions and multiple avenues and from
multiple agencies and I think the
American people need to know that this
is the worst possible abuse of power
think of at taxpayer expense and I will
say this I've taken the oath of office
three times I've sworn my through the
Constitution three times and we have any
number of people many high-ranking
people in the Obama administration that
took the same oath and they wouldn't
know it if it came up and bit them on
the butt Michael do you like that that's
a powerful statement Michael you nearly
lost your house I from what I understand
American people stepped up to help you
real quick they really did and I'll tell
you if it weren't for the American
people you know given the money to pay
for my legal fees
and more legal fees I'm starting to pay
other people's legal fees this thing is
really outrageous you mean you know what
I'll tell you today I spent photocopying
papers about a jealous husband that what
happened after the election just for
Robert Muller
that's how ridiculous this is ho pics
spent more on lawyers than she did make
trying to serve a country last word
Carter quick the Senate should demand
that Sam is brought on as the Under
Secretary of Agriculture immediately
given all of your thing he's been
through will have you guys back your
story is important this can't happen in
our country otherwise where the former
Soviet Union or the